[Music]
hi it's Michele from lab muffin beauty
science here chemistry PhD and big fan
of sunscreen
summer is coming for those of you in the
northern hemisphere and that means the
Sun is coming out and with it all of the
sunscreen myths ever so today I'm going
to go through the top sunscreen myths in
my opinion if I've missed your favorite
or least favorite myth leave me a
comment so I know to include it next
time if you want to know more about how
to choose and use the sunscreen that's
right for your skin you can check out my
ebook the lab muffin guide to basic skin
care how does the sunscreen chapter is
available as a sample on my site check
it out with the link below and of course
if you like this sort of video click the
thumbs up subscribe and click the
notification bellow
let's start with the first myth SPF 50
is only a little bit better than SPF 30
this myth turns up a lot and it goes
something like this
SPF 15 blocks 93% of UV SPF 30 blocks
97% of UV SPF 50 blocks 98% of UV and
since SPF 50 only blocks 1% more UV than
SPF 30 it isn't worth using SPF 50 for
the tiny amount of extra protection this
is one of the most persistent myths even
amongst dermatologists it's so
persistent that a group of sunscreen
scientists wrote a letter published in
JM a dermatology same media and health
professionals often incorrectly state
that SPS beyond 30 of the only minor
improvements in sun protection I talked
about this myth before in my video on
the meaning of SPF the reason for this
myth is that it looks at the amount of
UV block rather than the amount of UV
that the sunscreen allows into your skin
SPF 30 allows one and a half times as
much UV into your skin compared to SPF
50 it's actually more accurate to say
that it's a hundred and fifty percent as
effective or fifty percent more
effective you'll get burnt one and a
half times as fast with SPF 30 for
example this bears out in practice as
well with multiple studies showing that
the amount of protection scales with the
SPF number there's a study where people
applied SPF 100 plus sunscreen on one
side of their face and SPF 50 plus on
the other side after six hours of
activity in the Sun more than half the
people were more sunburned on the
spf50 side while only 5% of people were
more sunburned on the SPF 100 side if we
do the math according to the myth SPF
100 will only be 1% more effective so
this result makes no sense but according
to the way we should be measuring it SPF
100 plus is twice as effective which
explains the results way better so what
we should be doing instead according to
the science is to just use the SPF
number as a guide to the amount of
protection we get when we actually use
the sunscreen on our skin in other words
SPF correlates with clinical
effectiveness you can make an effective
DIY sunscreen from zinc oxide powder or
diaper cream no don't do this it might
save some money in the short term but do
you know what costs even more skin
cancer I have a whole video on the
reasons why giy sunscreen is a bad idea
but basically you can't make sure that
you've made a product that's going to
keep the zinc oxide spread evenly on
your skin at home it's hard enough for
cosmetic chemists to do it with
industrial machines and prepare emulsion
systems and proper SPF testing so the
chance that you can do it at home with a
jar of zinc powder or diaper cream is
just minuscule you shouldn't play lotto
with your health like that wearing
sunscreen is worse for you than not
wearing sunscreen there are a few
reasons that people give to justify this
myth firstly that sunscreen filters are
bad for you because they can disrupt
your hormones and nanoparticles can
absorb into your body leading to various
diseases there are a few studies that
have found that some sunscreen filters
have potential hormonal effects the
problem is that most of these studies
were done on cell lines and animals so
they don't necessarily translate to
human effects at the amount used in
sunscreens results from animal studies
have been inconsistent and harmful
effects were only seen when very large
amounts of sunscreen chemicals were fed
to the animals one paper did actually
try to translate it to what happens in a
human and it found that the sunscreen
with the strongest hormonal effects
which is oxybenzone if you applied a
sunscreen with a large amount of it
you'd have to use it continuously for 35
years over a hundred percent of your
body to have a noticeable hormonal
effect there are a few studies on
whether sunscreen chemicals have
hormonal effects in humans
but the results have been mixed some
observational studies have found that
people with higher oxybenzone levels
tended to have some reproductive
characteristics but not others a trial
where and oxybenzone containing cream
was applied didn't have any effects on
reproductive hormones so while it's
possible that there's a hormonal effect
it's unlikely to be significant
according to what we currently know
there are also nanoparticles in
sunscreens zinc oxide and titanium
dioxide the inorganic physical
sunscreens are ground up into tiny
nanometer sized particles in lots of
sunscreens and this improves their sun
protection properties and stops them
from looking white on your skin it's
possible that they can absorb into your
body and have an effect but the studies
so far show that they don't make a past
the top dead layers of your skin the
stratum corneum unless you apply it to
broken skin the second reason for this
myth is that sun exposure has been
linked to better health the problem with
this is that it doesn't show that sun
exposure with sunscreen doesn't have the
same benefits there are a few scientific
studies that have found that people who
get more sun exposure tend to be
healthier one big issue with these
studies first off is that a lot of the
time it doesn't tell you the reasons why
people are or aren't getting sun
exposure if someone is sick with a
chronic illness or a terminal disease
they're not going to get out as much and
so they're going to get less Sun
exposure people who exercise more will
be healthier and live longer and as a
side-effect they end up getting more
sunlight so correlation doesn't
necessarily mean causation there are a
few studies that have controlled for
some of these variables and more sun
exposure still lead to better health but
this still doesn't mean that wearing the
sunscreen while you're getting the sun
exposure is a bad idea
the proposed reasons for why sun
exposure is good for us is mostly to do
with vitamin D and nitric oxide
production vitamin D is made in your
skin when you're exposed to UVB light
while nitric oxide is produced in your
body in response to UVA vitamin D is
good for bone health and there's also
evidence that it could be involved in
preventing cancer heart disease
metabolic syndrome and obesity nitric
oxide is good for cardiovascular or
heart health
there haven't been any Studies on nitric
oxide in sunscreen use but there's been
a couple of studies on vitamin D in
sunscreen since sunscreen reduces the
amount of UV
be that reaches your skin and causes you
to get a sunburn it seems logical that
sunscreen would decrease vitamin D
production but studies have found that
it actually has very little effect in
real life the reason seems to be that
most people don't apply sunscreen
sufficiently and even if you think you
do there are lots of spots that you'll
have to miss things like your scalp
between your fingers and so on and so
these little gaps are enough to get you
the UV for adequate vitamin D levels
there's a lot less research on nitric
oxide but since it's also UV on the skin
that causes the nitric oxide production
the best guess is that it will probably
be a similar story even if you use
sunscreen
you'll probably get enough sunlight for
nitric oxide there are a lot of benefits
to wearing sunscreen the main months are
obviously skin cancer prevention and
prevention of skin aging in Australia
skin cancer is the most common type of
cancer it represents over 80% of new
cancer cases every year melanoma which
is a particularly deadly form of skin
cancer is the fourth most common cancer
just by itself in 2018 there were 14 and
a half thousand new melanoma diagnosis
and 1,900 deaths from melanoma the
number of melanoma jeff's adjusted for
population size has been increasing as
well in 2016 melanoma skin cancer was
the 12th leading cause of cancer death
in Australia and it's estimated that it
was the eighth most common in 2018 about
10% of people diagnosed with melanoma
will die within five years there've been
Studies on the benefits of sunscreen use
and it's been found that it decreases
skin cancer and skin aging in the
biggest study on this so far conducted
in Australia daily sunscreen use led to
decreased signs of aging and invasive
melanoma sware about four times less
common another study estimated that the
melanoma rate in Norway in older women
could drop by 18 percent with the daily
use of an SPF 15 plus sunscreen the
recommendation in Australia is for
sensible sun exposure combined with
sunscreen based on the UV level if the
UV level is 3 or above in the middle of
the day you should be wearing sunscreen
but if not then it's recommended that
you should intentionally get some sun
exposure there's more information about
this in my video on vitamin D and
sun protection chemical sunscreen only
works if you apply it to bare skin
there's a myth that chemical or organic
sunscreens need to absorb into your skin
and bind before they start working but
actually all sunscreen ingredients both
chemical and physical or more correctly
organic and inorganic work mostly the
same way they form a film that can
absorb UV light and turn it into heat a
few ingredients like zinc oxide and
titanium dioxide and Tino Saab M will
also reflect and scatter a small amount
of UV but all sunscreen ingredients will
mostly be converting UV into heat energy
and all of these sunscreen ingredients
will work before you apply them on your
skin you should still be applying them
around 20 minutes before sun exposure
because the sunscreen product itself
needs to spread out and dry down and
form an even layer on your skin before
will be protecting your skin effectively
but this is for all sunscreens and not
just the chemical sunscreens makeup with
SPF gives you enough protection it's
tempting to see an SPF rating on your
foundation or BB cream and think that
it's enough to protect you but the
amount of makeup that you use is way too
tiny you need two milligrams of product
per square centimeter of skin to get the
SPF rating on the label if you use less
the SPF protection will decrease a whole
bunch as well I did the maths in my
video on sunscreen and makeup questions
you need around one point to your
grounds of product on your face to get
to milligrams per square centimeter with
my regular use I'd get maybe SPF true
from an SPF 50 powder and SPF 8 from an
SPF 50 foundation the other issue is
that makeup usually doesn't have
broad-spectrum protection so you won't
be protecting your skin adequately from
UVA rays especially the longer
wavelengths that don't need to be
blocked to get a high SPF rating
layering products with SPF doesn't
increase the SPF this myth says that
there's no benefit to layering multiple
SPF rated products because the total SPF
you'll get is the SPF of the product
with the highest SPF so if you wear a
moisturizer with SPF 15 and a sunscreen
with SPF 30 and a foundation with SPF 5
the highest you can get is SPF 30 this
is sort of true
true if you're applying two milligrams
per square centimeter of sunscreening
product and that's the maximum amount of
product you can fit on your face because
any extra product that you add will just
wipe off but almost no one applies this
much and even if you measure out your
sunscreen properly you probably aren't
applying it perfectly evenly so the
extra layers of SPF will give you more
protection or cover up for any
insufficient parts there's a study that
found that applying two layers of
sunscreen was effective at increasing
sun protection the subjects ended up
with about two and a half times more
protection but if you're layering
sunscreen there's also the possibility
that different sunscreen ingredients can
destabilize each other leading to less
protection so make sure you check that
there aren't any incompatibilities first
it's safest to stick to sunscreens with
similar active ingredients you don't
need to reapply sunscreen if you haven't
been in the Sun there's a myth that the
only reason you need to reapply
sunscreen is because the chemical
filters and them break down after they
absorb too much UV but this isn't the
only reason they can be rubbed off as
you there on your skin and less
sunscreen on your skin means more UV
gets through the sunscreen film also
breaks up and gets thinner over time a
couple of the older chemical or organic
sunscreen filters were also photo
unstable and this means they would break
down after too much UV exposure but a
lot of chemical filters Arthur to stable
and so they won't have this problem you
can think of it like a coat of paint a
photo unstable UV filter is like a paint
that changes color or gets bleached by
the Sun you need to repaint it if that
happens but you also need to repaint it
if the paint just chips off sunscreen
comes off a lot faster if you're being
active in the Sun but I'll also wear off
if you move around a lot in the shade
there's evidence that applying it once
daily still gives lots of benefits but
if you need higher sun protection or if
you're being very active then
reapplication is definitely a good idea
regardless of the amount of sun there
are a lot of other sunscreen myths too
like whether it's destroying coral reefs
and whether chemical or physical
sunscreens are better I've covered a lot
of these in my other videos on sunscreen
so I recommend checking them out if you
want to find out more if you're
interested in finding out how to choose
a sunscreen that's right for your skin
and how to use them most effectively
check out the loud muffin guide to basic
skincare leave me a comment with the
myths that I miss that you think are
important and again if you liked this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to my channel for more Beauty size
videos you can also check out my blog
and Instagram see you next time for more
beauty science